il faut dire ce que l'on voit mais par
dessus tout il faut voir ce que l'on
voit ces mots de peggy alain
finkielkraut
on avait fait une exigence
intellectuelle il en avait fait en
quelque sorte sa devise
mes deux filles samedi ces mots ont une
résonance particulière
ce déferlement de haine ces mots ces
images virale insupportable que nous
avons tous vu mes chers collègues elle
nous oblige ces images elles nous
obligent précisément avoir avoir
justement que il y a bien sûr cette
montée inquiétante d'actes antisémites
dans notre pays
mais avoir aussi un surgissement le
surgissement d'un nouvel antisémitisme
qui comme l'ancien comme l'ancien s'en
prend à nos compatriotes au nom d'une
idéologie d'une idéologie qui n'est pas
celle des années 30 mais qui est tout
aussi dangereuse et curieusement et
curieusement ce nouvel antisémitisme a
trop longtemps été niée minimiser voire
même relativiser pour de fausses raisons
pour de mauvaises justification bien
souvent elles aussi idéologique
rappelons le mes chers collègues avec
fermeté un antisémite est un antisémite
qu'il soit fascistes ou frérot
salafistes
alors oui monsieur le premier ministre
bien sûr ce soir nous marcherons mais
marché ne suffit pas ne nous devons pas
marché les yeux bandés
oui à l'union sacrée mais non mais non à
une union qui écarterait la lucidité
monsieur le premier ministre il faut
haut et fort avoir le courage de dire
qu'il y ait un lien de cause à effet
entre ce cet islamisme et
l'antisémitisme
mais je ne crois pas nous ne croyons pas
que vous pourrez couper le lien
idéologique
justement avec ce lien civique sans me
mettre en cause je viens de physique
ce trajet lite et la laïcité
vous changez la loi de 1905 monsieur le
premier ministre ma question pensez vous
que modifier la loi de 1905 soit le bon
remède on veut répondre la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président retail beaucoup
d'aspects dans votre question une
dénonciation dans laquelle je me
retrouve bien évidemment d acte
antisémite de l'agression dont a été
victime alain finkielkraut
vous avez cité p dit on sait
l'attachement de la finkielkraut
ap eli lilly a dédié un livre le mes
contemporains nous avons assisté avec
consternation et peut-être même avec une
forme de colère et de rage au ventre à
cette mise en cause cru assumer brutale
d'un homme qui représente il n'est pas
le seul à le représenter mais la figure
de l'intellectuel engagé dans le débat
républicain vous n'acceptez pas assez
mis en cause vous dénoncer
l'antisémitisme
moi aussi c'est indispensable de le
faire je le disais tout à l'heure ça
n'est pas suffisant il faut dénoncer
il ne faut pas s'arrêter là il faut
avoir et vous nous y avait invité la
lucidité de reconnaître que
l'antisémitisme est à bien des égards
profondément enracinée dans la société
française et dans l'histoire française
non pas que la france serait aussi
antisémite
il ya toujours eu dans les moments les
plus sombres des femmes et des hommes
parfois des institutions qui ont su
défendre ce que nous pensons de notre
pays ce que nous croyons de notre pays
mais il faut reconnaître que depuis bien
longtemps dans l'histoire de france
des formes d'antisémitisme parfois
varier coexistent
certaines se développe à certains
instants et semble ensuite s'adoucir si
j'ose dire
alors que d'autres se développerait plus
vite vous avez évoqué le développement
d'un antisémitisme qui serait tissu
d'une radicalisation de l'islam qui
seraient issus des théories salafistes
qui parfois peuvent prévaloir dans
certains lieux et dans certains esprits
il existe ce que je veux monsieur le
président
retailleau c'est ne rien cacher ne rien
ignorer de ce phénomène de
l'antisémitisme en france il n'est
l'apanage l'antisémitisme d'aucune
formation politique et il a été à
différentes périodes de l'histoire
malheureusement largement partagée
combattre l'antisémitisme
c'est un combat dont nous savons qu'il
est redoutablement difficile il faut
l'aborder avec détermination avec une
détermination je dirais presque sauvage
mais il faut aussi l'aborder avec la
lucidité de ceux qui savent que c'est un
combat qui dure depuis longtemps et qui
d'état finit un peu d'humilité face à la
difficulté
reconnaissons le ensemble peut permettre
peut permettre de ne pas et je parle
pour moi comme pour tous ceux qui sont
ambitieux dans ce domaine peut permettre
de ne pas nous payer simplement de mots
oui nous devons livrer ce combat en dix
ans ou l ennemi oui nous devrons livrer
ce combat en faisant le pari de
l'intelligence
il faut toujours faire ce pari de
l'éducation il faut toujours faire ce
pari de la formation
oui nous devons être plus sévère
juridiquement si j'ose dire compléter
nos dispositifs juridiques quand ils
doivent l'être incité autant que cela
est possible dans un pays qui promeut la
séparation des pouvoirs la justice à se
montrer sévère face à ses actes et de ce
point de vue monsieur le président je
n'ai aucune hésitation j'ai appelé à
l'union sacrée sans hypocrisie sans
exclusive sans incohérence vous avez
peut-être été frappée je l'ait été par
tous ceux qui après ces actes contre
alain finkielkraut contre alain
finkielkraut disait je les dénonce mais
eh bien monsieur le président n'y a pas
deux mais quand on combat
l'antisémitisme le combat point
totalement complètement c'est mon
intention
[Applaudissements]